[Music]
thank you
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening
good middle of the night if that's where
you are and welcome to side Trek your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and I am
with those guys
stormy Bear say hello me hello mate
accent next time just to freak people
out and then I over that little Harris
what's happened with it babe I know I'll
I'll clean shaving and baby face now
I dropped a few years
oh I got my uh I'm sorry you just looked
like you're 12 years old should we be in
the same room with him alone I mean I'm
unsure how these rules go
you're going to get carded for baby food
Jesus
I wish I got carded
it's been a long time since I've been
asked for ID it used to be such a
nuisance I've always looked five years
younger than I am which is nice now I'm
44.
but um when I was like 23 trying to pull
girls
not so much no no I mean go honest
see I look five years younger than I am
without a beard and then with the beard
I'm hanging out with people five years
older than me most of the time so it's
it's a little bit everything you know or
too old coaches like us every
but
anyway guys
welcome to scitrix Sunday where we talk
about whatever the hell we want but this
week has been a bit of an interesting
week
we've had a very interesting episode of
Andor we've had the season finale of
She-Hulk which has caused some
controversy and I've already done one
video or I moan about that a great deal
and oh some of the comments I got in
return were lovely but anyway
um and we've got this rings of power
season finale which was very interesting
still a little boring but we'll get into
that oh yeah
um
sorry stormy guys
shall we talk about She-Hulk first if
that's okay yeah
so before I ran too I'm very aware
sometimes I talk a lot on these and I
need to button my lip so before I talk a
lot
of you guys jump in first and I'll just
try and pick them up
I'll start it was good that wasn't wrong
it took no time for him to butt in swear
to God I can't get a word out because
Jesus Christ
I didn't dislike it but I didn't like it
I I'm much more
I'm leaning towards dislike I'm still
kind of I I you saw my tweet Jamie I
took a nice fat dab prior to watching
that show and the second the fourth wall
was broken I was like what did I just
smoke what is going on like
what year is it I I didn't know what was
happening but
I like the idea of of what they did I
liked the fourth wall break and I like
some of the implications that might have
going forward but also
I really did not I I didn't like the way
they did it this I saw I believe it was
new rock stars they put about a video
and they literally juxtaposed it against
the season finale for Loki and it's it's
bullet point cut for cut the exact same
thing done a different way instead of a
big action it's uh a big kind of a
dialogue sequence between two people and
it's supposed to be this emotional thing
but instead of
being a character inside of a world that
we're obviously watching It's supposed
to be inside of our world but obviously
it's not inside of our world because
what Jessica gal and the showrunners
wrote all of this during
the pandemic so they weren't ever in a
writer's room like that and they weren't
ever on the the Burbank lot in Disney
like that so that was also false so it's
technically a world within a world and
and now there's just more questions uh
but with all that I just I don't I don't
think we got any actual
growth for She-Hulk she's exactly where
she started out at the beginning of the
season is she gonna be a lawyer is she
going to be a Hulk did we actually did
nothing happened is is
I didn't dislike the season as a whole
but just but but nothing happened it's
and I understand it as a comedy so that
can kind of play into that but I didn't
laugh really the entire season either
and nothing was really like it wasn't
those Rick and Morty laughs I was
expecting from the woman that wrote
pickle Rick you know I I expected a lot
more and I just it never delivered
wanted to
except the Daredevil walkout scene that
that the torque scene those were good
but besides that
there weren't really that many great
jokes one of the better jokes was in
this past episode though uh well what
what what did Tatiana maslani say as she
said uh
I I smashed smashed this smash this
smash Matt Murdock that was pretty funny
but besides that you know ah what am I
watching a comedy or am I watching just
a a middling MCU show kind of tear
itself apart you know what I'd like to
see I mean you brought about the idea of
the the fourth wall being broken all the
time I was I'm
somewhere inside me there's a little boy
that would love to see the last Picard
Series where lore is breaking the fourth
wall you know with slapstick comedy I
think that would just I mean in ruin the
series of course but hey anything else
have been ruined so why not have lore
you know making commentary into the
fourth wall throughout the entire thing
yeah I mean I'm just saying why not why
can't we have that I would love it with
the fourth wall then it's good I think I
think the breaking the focals because
what's that in the comics right now I've
actually read a couple of She-Hulk
Comics since this because somebody said
it's in the comments this is a comic
sorry it's in keeping with that so I
read a couple of comics online and and
she hooked it did break the photo
occasionally
is is the thing with the show though
that that it's not the fact that they
broke down before they did it too much
it's just it's like over and over and
over and it got a bit stale
for me I think the the fourth wall
breaking thing works you know that
little look to the camera and stuff that
they're doing some shows it works if you
use it sparingly if you do it too much
it it loses its
fun and it loses the point of it sort of
thing
two
in the last episode I I would kind of
disagree with the rest of the series I
thought they used it really well
throughout the rest of the series that
once or twice per episode is kind of
like all right it's there but we're not
thinking about it all the time and when
it happens it's it's a good chuckle and
that's usually where it was funnier I
think the issue there is it just the
rest of the show legitimately just
wasn't funny enough to
to keep us entertained and to keep that
entertainment level I guess at that same
degree as the jokes that would come off
as more meta and
that that fourth wall commentary that
was kind of more
oh maybe she needs to be singing during
her fourth wall commentary you know like
Tim Curry and Rocky Horror he did a lot
of uh uh fourth wall kind of stuff
looking at the camera but he was always
singing maybe she just needs to
Deadpool's got a
lot of talks on camera or towards the
camera so yeah maybe I'm just you know
let's just throw [ __ ] out there why not
we got the fourth wobble we might as
well add singing with lore in Picard
with that show I wouldn't be surprised
you know I mean with the card or yolk I
guess
Star Trek to keep Brent Spiner in that
TV show any way possible
um and he loves to sing so why not but
um with the She-Hulk okay my other one
issue I do is she haul cause it was
obviously a big middle finger to the
trolls and to the anti-woke
people and that was that's very clear
um my argument is though that the that
was that seems to be more important than
actually having some sort of story
because again I had a look at the
She-Hulk comics
and there was always a story to them she
would break the fourth walls he would
even go and see the writers I think
Ellie uh yeah they mentioned that a
comment they would go and see the right
stuff well there was in the comics I
read anyway I only read two or three
there was always still like an end to a
story you know there was a something
would happen and then she would punch
somebody in the face really hard and
she she'd win there was still a Marvel
story to it I don't think this thought
this Series has a Marvel story shoot at
all
if if you actually think about it the
the all of the build up through the six
episodes was completely pointless
because none of them were going anywhere
I mean the whole thing about um them
trying to get her blood you know that
one scene where they come and they beat
her up with magical tools and they're
trying to get a blood but the needle
won't go in
that was pointless because it didn't go
anywhere
she literally asked a question of a
robot and that plot line just
dropped
yeah I found that a little frustrating
but but this is a big thing you know
middle finger to uh I actually gave the
bird then off screen then did you see it
I'm not sure I'm allowed to you but
anyway they did that to trolls and
um
uh and the anti-work people but but
again though did they do it too much
I don't know I it's
but I thought the story
meandered and I think some of the
episodes meandered within the episodes
and the meanderings had me Andrew it's
just there was a lot of loose ends at
didn't get like any Exposition later on
it was
I mean it's entertaining to watch we've
got nothing else to do I mean you know I
mean it wasn't bad you know it wasn't
Ishtar bad
but it was just
um
it's not something I'm gonna go back and
re-watch you know like I will re-watch
the [ __ ] out of the Rings of power I
already have you know I'll I'll re-watch
um
you know maybe penny worth or something
like oh a lot of times every time every
time we get on this thing on this live
stream we talk about what we've
rewatched
and those you know even though some of
the stories are good or bad or whatever
or just don't really rise to the level
we will re-watch the entire series all
50 Seasons or whatever because we they
are good yeah I I I am sorry to say I
mean I know the actor the the actors in
in the Act and the actresses really put
their heart into this but I kind of
think the writers let him down there
wasn't any there was nothing there
to make me re-stream it again you know
what I mean it's it's like okay I
consumed it it's pop and material
you know it's like all this pop music
you don't want to go buy the album
you know
I mean it was different you can't argue
that it wasn't different they did
something different I mean not you know
no no I was just gonna say like the I
feel like all of the performances and
all the acting was exactly what it was
meant to be and and all very well done
just the writing wasn't there and and I
mean you can see that I keep bringing up
the comedy aspect of it I don't think
they had comedy writers I mean they had
Jessica gal but
I it just didn't feel like
the show had a soul is a good way to say
it it felt like that Soul meandered
around and then that meandered me ended
off somewhere else uh it was a good way
of saying that
um
did Jay's original point of was there
too much or too little uh
or I guess was there too much of the
anti-woke stuff it it was either too
much or too little in a way where it
didn't have a soul it there wasn't that
one kind of pivotal thing to hold on to
for the series
and it just kept Meandering you we got
kind of a couple little MCU stories in
there like Daredevil kinda had his own
little miniature aspect of things but
with that we should have seen a
prolonged law kind of plot at some point
a two or three four episode law plot Arc
is the Hulk's MCU story in here where he
brings a son back is that supposed to
feel gratifying because that did not
feel gratifying sure they could give us
a planet Hulk movie or a TV show
something like that and bring us back
into that but I I just leave at the end
of episode one have a phone call a
little cameo in the Middle episode two
and then be kind of I guess
dangled at us like a carrot in the
beginning of the last episode just to
kind of actually come back and have a
son at the end of the episode
that none of the writing was there to
bring us to that point
I don't know how we got to a fast and
furious family greet meet and greet
having Coronas and boom boom Tyrese
Gibson and Dwayne The Rock Johnson walks
in obviously they don't but yeah it felt
like a fast and furious franchise moment
there when it it didn't earn who's who's
this family we've seen the mom and dad
and the brother we've seen the dad a
little bit more but we've seen them
twice they got technically just as much
screen time as Daredevil or the Hulk but
it wasn't rewarding and that I don't
know I I don't dislike the show overall
but that's I think it's pivotal
downfall is it it didn't have a soul and
how are we supposed to be rewarded as
people watching it with Souls that that
want that we want to feel a little happy
warm feeling at the end of the show or
we wanted to actually make us think and
and stuff like that and I think it tried
to do both and failed it both instead of
just picking I think one of the things
is with it with this type of show is
that it's it's obviously fiction but you
can you you know you fall into the show
you know it's it's almost like it's
important part of your brain that almost
wants it to be real and you know you get
absorbed into it sort of thing so when
then something happens you have an
emotional response I think because they
break down in the fourth wall so much it
doesn't feel real so you have no
connection to it so then when something
does happen you just don't really care
and the whole thing with the Hulk at the
end and go another Cinema's car
if you'd have blink should have missed
it and even if you did didn't miss it
again you don't care
um and I just think it was it was just
such a shame because actually I love the
actress that plays She-Hulk I think
she's amazing the Tatiana
and the The Hulk character I thought was
great
I didn't mind the CGI even though they
were it was weak in places
um
and and all these things a lot of people
have complained about didn't bother me
because I can appreciate it's still a TV
show
and you know they're not going to you
know they make little jokes don't they
about like uh should I turn back into
Jennifer now because you know like the
screen cost things and I was like yeah
yeah I can prove it that is actually an
issue and this is yeah because you're
very expensive it's like okay that black
panther drum roll after was pretty damn
funny too yeah yeah there were some
really good bits in this but I I feel
that the agenda and I'm
I feel like the word that word is a bit
a bit more loaded than I mean it to be
but the point of the show was to stick
two fingers up at people anti-word
controls and stuff like that and that
was more important than any story
mm-hmm and that's a shame that that's
what made me come away with a bit of
taste in my mouth thinking I've wasted
my time watching that
can you see my point there
the other thing that annoyed me though
and I did actually finish watching this
and I did sort of like crossed my arms
and think
was it I felt like Marvel giving a
little bit of a two fingers up to
um Marvel fun
um it was like the whole bit at the end
when she sort of like what what do you
want to do with abomination well I would
just like them to take
um some responsibility for what he's
done
and you know it almost felt like well if
you want to Big Punchy up
Marvel ending that's childish and we're
not going to do that we're going to do
something a bit more grown up I'm not
just that like
well that's like I I wanted a big
puncture beef you know and so is that
was that wrong for some reason so I even
felt like they were sort of like
almost like telling us not not telling
us off that's a bit much but it was a
bit of a almost like insulting Marvel
fans as a whole
I don't know I don't know I just wish
this show if if they'd done everything
but had an end had a point to it I
wouldn't have come away from it almost
annoyed but Abomination just going I'm
sorry I'm gonna go write a Haiku I'm
like oh [ __ ] off the whole series has
obviously been building up towards the
fact that it was him that was trying to
corrupt She-Hulk and get her blood and
do something with it because all of the
people that were trying to get the blood
or it is [ __ ] camp
so it was it was obvious maybe it was
too obvious
ly
that
that or introduced The Leader the leader
is supposed to be the the leader of that
intelligencia group I I expected him to
show up honestly at some point
because he was confirmed Captain America
new world order as well and She-Hulk is
I guess
rumored to be in that film as well and
if I don't see how that was set up I I
mean if the intelligencia just existing
is supposed to set that up I don't think
I did it all that great of a job but it
did kind of feel like a big Fu to Marvel
fans in the same way that
Ralph boner felt like a Fu to fans in
the one division finale it was kind of
like oh you have all these theories and
you think this one character could be
cool no it's there just for the sake of
being there
and it's kind of what Kevin felt like
even though it was cool I really did
like a lot of the meta aspects of it it
was a complete rehash of Kang and Loki
but trying to be meta and I I don't it
it which what fans are supposed to watch
that and feel satiated from that I don't
know I I don't know if
feeling satiated from that I guess is
what we're all looking for and I don't
know who's supposed to feel satiated
from watching that episode
yeah it didn't like there wasn't like
this oh
that was a good show you know wow yeah
that's really cool you know um and going
back to uh one of uh Jay's points about
the the
especially about the fourth wall if
there is any more fourth wall they
should have just hired Morgan Freeman to
narrate the damn thing I swear to God
you know I mean it was it was I mean it
wasn't a continuous thing but you know I
can just hear Morgan Freeman and here
they come for her blood notice how the
criminals you know it was just like get
Morgan Freeman to narrate the thing and
just let her do her lines it would have
been much better I'm just saying but
yeah I think it's just I just think it's
unfortunate because you're such a good
actress and I really like the character
this is not a criticism against the
actress at all they they did very very
well with what they had
I did actually get accused by a guy and
we talked it through and I explained to
him that I wasn't at all but he
um that sort of suggest that I was
actually like um supporting the
anti-woke people and sort of like and I
I made it sound like I was just
attacking that anything with a female
lead and that was not my point at all I
thought she was great yeah and I thought
the character was great I just think the
agenda of what they were trying to say
overtook any show
and also there's the crime of that it
just wasn't funny and it's supposed to
be and it's attorney at law
yeah there was very very little legal
stuff going on in there I'd have I'd
have preferred if they'd have made
illegal drama I've started watching
Boston Legal again with um will Shatner
and um and oh [ __ ] it's got James Spade
I love that show and that's that's a
comedy that's got silliness that they
break the fourth wall all the time in
that they keep talking about how it's
like sweep sweep and stuff and they've
got to try and get the viewer flickers
up and things and it's that's brilliant
but it's still like got a story to it
um yeah
I'd I'd have liked to have seen a bit
more of that if they wanted to do
something different do that but instead
they made an anti-woke propaganda series
well they presented the series to us as
an Ally McBeal styled law series hmm oh
my God I think we got it too lost maybe
three in the whole series
if they only had a unisex bathroom and
it would have helped
yeah yeah it's good exactly some
procedurally stuff in there would have
been fun yeah but anyway
I saw oh yeah I did hate it but I don't
hate it enough to I've I've said my
piece
good now
um I do hope that anybody that watches
my She-Hulk video goes back and actually
listens to what I'm saying like so I've
got a few comments and I've jumped in
and I've gone like no come on that's not
what I've said
um but uh you know I I'm not supporting
the anti-worker you know what I think
about the woke word I hate it I'm not a
fan of the book word that's so welcome
you I know
um but um but I I don't like it because
of where it came from and what it
actually means and but anyway I lose
about 10 subscribers every time I
mention what I don't like
so so my question after watching
She-Hulk yeah are you more likely to go
back and watch this season again where
to go back and watch Thor 11 Thunder
again
oh my god oh okay
drive off all the audience why not this
let's just shut down now and quit damn
I don't want to watch it either
I tried too much love and thunder again
I got about halfway through and I have
to turn it off
Oh I thought I've got to give it a
chance I'm being unfair maybe I just
maybe I was just too looking forward to
it I was expecting Ragnarok too and I
was just then disappointed by so I
thought sometimes sometimes you know you
build yourself up so much and then you
watch it and I'm disappoint you it's not
what I was expecting but then you watch
it again and you're like got it yeah and
so I tried to watch it again
at least they made werewolf by night
they're they're doing something good
thank you I really enjoyed that but
we're getting a second series of
She-Hulk
yay not watching
um fingers crossed uh where it looks
like we're 100 getting a second season
and we're getting the second season that
Miss Marvel and I still haven't watched
that either but anyway okay
well you know I watched this Marvel and
it's a really good kid show
yeah apparently there's a few bits and
Bobs in there we need you need to know
for later bits but um I don't know I
honestly think Marvel's in Decline at
the moment and I really hope they sort
it out
I think they're doing quality over
quantity and I hope they slow down
is it Marvel or Disney do you think a
soon decline
well here's my question here here's the
real question and this deserves its
whole video swear to God
is Pinhead a Disney princess now
yes technically
is pin is print Pinhead now the
Halloween princess you know it's oh
that's a good girl yeah
I suppose so we've got xenobite
princesses now and it's fantastic
so the is the chatterer a Disney prince
technically too
I guess
now that's not a dinner party I want to
go to but
will there be singing
oh God
you won't be able to understand
I've just seen that comments Agent
Carter was fantastic particularly the
first season I loved Agent Carter I
loved Agent Carter man I mean
how it was just absolutely raw from not
getting a second season it was ju or 13
it was just great it was great I
actually bought it for for streaming
just because I loved it so much it was
really really good that seriously been a
couple of years later when Disney plus
was up and running and it had gone
straight to Disney plus we've got five
or six seasons of that yeah it's just it
was on the wrong Network people didn't
quite get it and it didn't get the
following and it got canceled but uh
just a couple of years later it would
have been fantastic if it would have
been part of that Netflix era it would
have been well done too yeah it just
happened to be ABC and I guess
viewership was switching to streaming
more so during that time period and it
just kind of screwed it over yeah but
she was fantastic
too one of the best bits I thought she
was amazing so yeah
um so Eli's just said I hope we get to
see you again the rumor is we are going
to get to see her again and the rumor is
there is going to be a possibly another
Captain Carter series
so but it'll be a different format but I
can't remember the rumor now I'm telling
you that and I can't remember but I'm
sure that was the gist of it anyway
right
Andor
or should we do rings of power well
because it'll be a little one they will
end on rings I think we might end up
talking about for a while and or
basically I just I just wondering what
you guys thought but in a nutshell
bloody hell it was good
um I loved it I mean it's uh
uh a guy a friend of mine at work is
just
um
I I think he's of the mind that there
shouldn't be any Star Wars series it was
these are movies there shouldn't be TV
series and so I always taunt them yeah
what did you think of the last Andor
because I know he's never watched it I
don't think I think he watched maybe bad
batch or something else but he's been
very down on Andy he you know I think
he's I think he's one of the trolls
online that just types into the into the
night bitching about uh Star Wars series
but you know it's um I like I mean it
it's more Star Wars it was it was a I
thought
the Andor as a character was a an odd
choice at first to have his own spin-off
series I thought he did a very good job
of the actor did a very good job in
world one
but he was just like
wow they made a spin-off series out of
him
you know I mean
really
but and I thought he was like wow
they're really running out of material
but oh my God was it really a good show
um it was more of a
I mean it was like uh it explained a lot
of the inner workings of um
of the uh Rebel Alliance at his top
tiers in the Senate and how it was
represented and um
I just I don't know I just I just really
liked it so
you know the answer work people can come
out and accuse me of something I guess
and that'll just
they'll always accuse you of something
um
no I like the point they make about it
being like procedural and we're getting
to see the roots of the thing I still I
love how they did a firefly you know the
AK-47 was actually a laser gun and so
that was very horrible of them they have
these like you know retro looking goods
and it's like
um but yeah do you know the main thing
about this was it's been a bit boring up
till now I don't really think it I don't
think it has because it's building up so
much and it's quite procedural in a way
it's like this is why we're at this but
it's got a lot to explain but then that
the Charis nemic was a character
actually cared about when he got
squished I was like oh man I like that
guy
um and I'm actually
yeah
well I just like I just thought they
built them up really nicely and but I'm
actually more excited about where this
is going next when I maybe wasn't after
the fourth or fifth episode I was a
little bit like okay come on
um this Rebellion sucks
um but actually now I'm like
where are they going with this they're
getting somewhere yeah
Circle this is I mean we've seen more I
mean this is the and we also got uh as a
parting gift we got a really good
backstory on my mothma
yeah you know
yeah
I I think we're getting lots of really
lots of depth of color of
of a lot of stuff building up to the
Star Wars movie it's it's just adding to
I thought the same about um Rogue one
that it's just it added so much and this
just is adding to that it's I think it's
great
and we're going to get Alan judic at one
point is that that robot a C30 I forgot
his name
um k2so k2so thank you um which is great
Alan tudik and everything is amazing
um we're gonna get um we're gonna get a
few really good characters coming
through in the next one I gotta look at
the I made the mistake of looking at
IMDb and look at the list of actors that
are in it and I'm like ah there's some
freaking good active Forest Whitaker is
going to be in this at some point
um great actor um I don't know what his
characters are doing bother looking at
the character
um but um no I'm really excited about
where this is going in the last few
episodes and would you know as well I
assume this is going to be one season I
thought it's only supposed to be one of
these and I'm thinking no no it's got to
be at least two isn't it oh they're
filming the second one right now
this season one is supposed to be a year
like the first year of the Rebellion
season two where I believe I don't know
if it's 11 or 12 episodes I forget I
know season one is 11 episodes I think
season 12 is two episode or 12 episodes
and the way they're doing it is every
either three or every four episodes is
another year up to the rebellion and
they're doing like the first five years
leading up to Rogue one leading up to
the Rebellion so they're essentially
working alongside Star Wars Rebels those
five years leading into the Rebellion
leading into Rogue one and a new hope
I feel a bit stupid now I knew that
let's just explain the way oh yeah I
remember that I'm pretty sure I remember
saying that on this channel
[ __ ] forgot that it's gonna be great
so much information goes in my brain
some of it leaks out my ears my wife
says a lot leaks out my ears but
um
but but yeah I I I absolutely love it I
actually think that might be the my the
favorite thing I've watched this weekend
or was
um it was I just thought it was
fantastic
dragon
oh House of dragon was great as well oh
that was good the species
bringing that up real quick though
and stormy's not gonna like me for this
one away
no no I'm not spoiling I'm I'm talking
about the levels of slowness here so I
don't find and or boring at all I uh and
I will start it out by saying that I I
love Slow Burn films I watched first cow
three times when it was in movie
theaters and if anybody's ever seen
first cow that is the definition of a
slow burn film and and you know it's
okay I I like that kind of drawn out I
like to kind of be in that world more
sometimes
but I don't necessarily think that's
what we're getting with Andor I think a
lot it's not necessarily Exposition
because it's all necessary for story
similar in the way House of the Dragons
doing it where rings of power was just
boring for the most of the season I I
liked all the story points of rings of
power but it was drawn out and and
almost it was just boring compared to
yes we're just getting a lot of dialogue
essentially in house the dragon and
Andor up until now
but that that fuse has to be lit and it
has to be that strong and long of a fuse
for that I guess explosiveness to be
that good the rings of power it didn't
let me down
but it's it it didn't meet expectations
either
um I I see it similar to uh the pros in
The Hobbit versus the silver alien if
you've ever read The Hobbit
you know it's just a couple
um it's just a few chapters and they're
being slow roasted by the trolls the
silmarillion
is a slow burn book I mean it is
I I read this meme the top 10 things a
writer doesn't do you know and it
violated every single one of them and uh
but you know where The Hobbit was really
action-packed sequencing sequence uh
rich just boom boom boom boom out of The
Frying Pan Into the Fire kind of thing
Silmar alien wasn't and I'm sometimes
I'm wondering if rings of power because
it's trying to tell the story across
in years that it should be a little bit
more but it isn't and it's honor it is
on a real slow burn
now the the
um I think you get an opportunity for a
lot of character developed like I'm in
love with the harfots and how they wrote
all that that all of those scenes but
you're right it's it's like some
morelian versus The Hobbit and The
pacing is completely different well I I
hate to even because it's it it was
going
it wasn't necessarily doomed to fail
running up alongside House of the Dragon
but at the same time both of the
legitimate stories there span over a
very long period of time and how should
the dragon I feel like well rings of
power was like all right we're gonna cut
that time period down and make it make
sense for a narrative story where how
should the dragon found an Exquisite way
of telling that longevity of a story and
the house of the Dragon they've set
themselves up where if you want to have
a two or three or four-year prequel
series with young runera if you want to
have another smaller prequel series with
the current renera and Harwin strong you
can have them come in and do some other
stuff we're obviously getting the
coreless spin off rings of power could
have set themselves up where all right
have a couple episodes and then if
they're gonna spend that type of money
make them good tell tell a longevity
story and set the the seeds for those
spin-off series if you really want to
have those I don't know obviously that's
that's a little too compare contrast
with House of the Dragon which I I don't
want to do but also it's hard not to do
with both of those heavy time periods
done the way they've been done do you
think Amazon made a mistake releasing
lord of the things of power right now
because it is running side by side with
Game of Thrones yeah
you know they shouldn't have re released
it you know at the same time so they'd
be running at the same time they should
have had they should have been the the
principal fantasy show and had that by
themselves that they've had to share it
with HBO you know and it that's a
programming mistake I don't think that's
a filmmaker original writers would think
they're just kind of locked into what
the contract is yeah and I know they
were trying to get it on screen as soon
as possible to fulfill the uh their uh
contractual obligations with talk in the
state I mean Harris was talking about uh
spin-offs and
um
I figured we'd be I figured we'd be
talking about that so I dragged out oh a
little book of mine and this is what we
really need
I'm Bombadil you know that's a little
book I got and for some reason the the
hardback version is only available in
the UK so I had to go to Amazon UK to
get it it just I don't know why but
they do ship to America the American
version was only in paperback because
we're such a disposable Society I guess
and it's illustrating so
you gotta get this Thomas this is the
trombone thank you very much
on a massive stack of books he's got
just off screen
I've got a I've got it I've got this uh
large window in the in the dining room
where I'm filming this and I've got this
shelf above it from what and it's like a
12-foot shelf and it's 10 foot of it is
talking books
Gandalf DeVito dies from giant book
stack
a bit chewy and we warned him we warned
him in the house we've warned him
I I do think that um we'll talk about
the let's say that's the comparison
between the two I was going to say it
has Lord of the Rings maybe some of the
shine been took off it because of Game
of Thrones and because of the because of
the shock value and stuff that you get
in Game of Thrones those moments in Game
of Thrones to do make you go oh Jesus
and which are regular you know they
happen every two or three episodes
um Lord of the Rings is generally one
um House of the dragons and Game of
Thrones is literally one of the only
shows I've ever sort of had to stop and
sort of go and have a walk around just
like think because you know there's a
few moments like the Red Wedding and
stuff that make it generally go that's
I'm pretty thick-skinned that's
genuinely shocking you know you you see
like these horror movies and they go oh
my God it made audiences throw up and I
watch and I go
Game of Thrones generally didn't make me
go okay I need a second
um but because of that and that's one of
the reasons what made it so brilliant
we are comparing it because it is a
fantasy swords Dragon series dragons
hello well rings of power doesn't have
those shock moments
so it comes across a little
boy
but I see I don't know if they don't
have those stock moments I feel like
they still have some and it's more
relative to it's it's much more
childlike in nature and more Fantastical
instead of grounded medieval kind of
fantasy it's more of that Adventure
fantasy type of of genre I guess but I
feel like those moments are still there
like tell tell me that scene where Iran
deer are getting all that orc blood in
his mouth isn't that's pretty pretty
and it that wouldn't be that vile if we
were watching Game of Thrones that would
be like all right first episode you're
watching fingers get chopped off you're
watching dicks get chopped off you're
watching Damon cut into anybody and
everybody walking through the the city
getting chopped off something you know
where one moment of of black gooey blood
dripping into the mouth and the face of
this one guy who's fairly Untouchable
not Untouchable fairly untouchable
I I feel like it's still relative and
they did some of those moments well like
the even when the stranger beats those
wolves down uh later on in the series
I I
just I feel like to to the relative
where it's the childlike media they did
well with that it's it's just the pacing
and the editing particularly have just
that's what slows it down if it would
have been edited differently I think we
with what we have if it was an edited
and a better pace and not so there were
some cheesy ass moments like I I still I
cannot stand the moment where Bronwyn
cuts that orc's head off and then the
next the next edit is her putting the
Orcs head onto the bar in front of all
the southlanders I'm just like there's
no gravitas there's no way that was a
bit of a quick edit there was a bit that
that it stuck with me and that's
aggravated me for the last six or seven
weeks just thinking about it
one thing that uh George RR Martin
admitted to is like you know yeah he
purposely made Game of Thrones all his
books you know violent
you know and violence is
I mean I think he was once quoted the
violence as a character in the story you
know and that was you know Tolkien
was that was that was not his thing he
he told these
I mean yeah uh if you look at how he was
influenced you know uh by sagas of
Europe the
thousand-year-old sagas of Europe like
the Icelandic Tales Etc uh he was uh he
he wrote in a mythological sense
you know he he he was not right you know
the
um
I mean yeah there were there was
violence in in these mythological Tales
of Europe but it was uh there was a
battle in the blah blah blah the dragon
you know were
um in Georgia R Martin has you know
was once criticized by his uh the way he
writes violence in the right way he
writes sex scenes is that he will write
with the same kind of uh energy
of sex as he was like a sword going
through the head
it was that kind of writing style and
I'm wondering if this is a comparison of
one Tolkien wrote mythology
and uh uh Martin is writing more of a
modern Tale
you see what I'm saying I mean the two
are you know are are different kind of
literary structures
yeah I mean Tolkien itself is it's no
matter what there is a definitive good
versus a definitive evil where George R
Martin his whole
ethos is there is no good or evil and
someone has to find that within
themselves one way or another based
around their environments their their
life their their decisions etc etc
it's it's just a different way of
approaching a similar kind of
Fantastical concept but very different
in the approach yeah oh yeah and so I
don't know so even on the surface
whereas they look similarly we you know
some people do make comparisons if you
scratch the service they're actually
very very different yeah it's like one
thing you're talking the talking analogy
of the Imp
huh
it ain't Samurai's game she you know
he's not the one running around brothels
or whatever was there even the broth
yeah and I'm trying to remember I think
there was even a brothel at all missing
brothels look at it
and Lord of the Rings
crazy
uh
the one thing I would say though about
the edited and stuff though is this I
would say
I do think they've done a very nice job
of keeping rings of power in style with
Lord of the Rings and that that's why
I've said so many people that claim to
be massive Lord of the Rings fans and
then shouting that this is boring thing
I'm watching it going it looks like
they've they've gone out of their way to
make it feel like remember the Lord of
the Rings is basically a film about
walking for a long time
um you know to say
yeah okay the battle scenes aren't there
yet you know the big exciting battle
scenes aren't there yet we've had a
couple of smaller battles but I would
say that the style is very very similar
so I don't really understand why the
bigger the some Tolkien fans are so
upset by it it seems strange that
worries me going into season two because
the one if they got something right for
rings of power it is the way it looks in
the way it feels
hmm and they're they're moving it from
New Zealand to the UK now and they're
already filming up in the UK and
that I mean Game of Thrones and the
house of the Dragon they've that's kind
of their primary place to film so I know
it can and and should look excellent and
I know you might be a little more privy
to the the UK landscape and know things
out there but
maybe the feelings like New Zealand's
the most beautiful place on this planet
you know
there's a lot of what we've already seen
is is just like Wales and Northern
Scotland it's gonna it's gonna look like
that obviously some of the Northern
Scotland backgrounds are going to be
stunning you you won't be coming but
it wasn't parts of Andor filmed in
Scotland I mean in that damn
isn't that in Scotland yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it is hydroelectric Dam in
Scotland yeah
I mean that's a stunning scenery up
there
well great but it doesn't
but I'm the only thing I'm worried about
there is that feel because you can I
don't know New Zealand just has that you
you know when you're looking at that
landscape versus
we don't have the snowy mountains and
things like that they're gonna have to
see GI some backgrounds which they hired
the best people in the world to do this
past season and that's one of the reason
it looks so good but how much harder are
they going to have to work and is that
going to take away from other aspects of
the show
I don't know we can only answer that
whenever it's out you know but but um I
mean like a lot of Middle Earth is like
rolling grassy Hills and Meadows and
things like that and we got them
coming at my backside they're everywhere
so and it will be significantly cheaper
to film it here than there
so I mean I suppose a signal and we've
got some of the the best movie studios
in the world
yeah and the talent you know to to
produce these things so there is that as
well but
um
but yeah I I thought that was always
part of the planner that they would do
the early stuff in New Zealand and they
haven't they filmed bits and bobs for
um lots of things and for the full Five
Seasons already haven't they bits
because they did that in New Zealand
knowing it was expensive but knowing
they were then going to move it over to
England so I don't I don't think it
wasn't to do with cost or anything it
was this was always part of the plan
wasn't it I think
um from what I read but I'm not sure but
hopefully
um
one criticism some people have had about
the rings of power was that the big
twists were very predictable
um I didn't realize actually that Hal
brand was people thought he was Sauron I
didn't see that coming at all
really
um apparently that was oh everyone knew
that it was so obvious what did we talk
about the very first thing you know
remember I said how brand was it wasn't
character there's lots of people
who've been you know yeah some random
guys
I should have realized I'm not going
back and thinking it was because the
connection I always realized the
connection between him and the King
character he'll tell me his name in a
second the Lord of the Rings King the
guy's name I can't pronounce
um
Aragon so thank you he's the connections
are too similar it was basically the
same story wasn't it that he was like
he was a nobody and they know really
he's the king yeah and he's the king of
he's the king of Mordor I mean
king of Mordor oh yeah
okay so it was on this then okay just
saying
no no listen to the cranky old American
but the Fallen star guy then I saw
another thing saying that well that's
Gandalf and I thought it wasn't Gandalf
uh
it might not be I'm still uh I I'm of
the mind that that is a misdirect
because they have given him a few lines
that are literally Gandalf lines like
follow your nose and and things like
that
which I love that line that when the
stranger talks he's had some of the best
lines of of the show uh
also in the last episode before that it
was just a lot but some of those little
moments were Gandalf moments that he had
like few words which were fun but I
think it's a mystery I want to say this
guy's a blue blue wizard I don't even
think he's radagast because that's where
I was going because of all the nature
stuff but I think he's a blue wizard
just because he's heading to the East
and Gandalf what does he say in uh is
The Hobbit or is it Fellowship where he
says I don't go to the east I go
everywhere but I don't go to the East
look at this and that's where the two
blue Wizards went was to the east
so I'm thinking the blue he's one of the
blue Wizards is is my guess
and I think it's just
you know there's a lot of lines
attributed to uh that he says that is
attributed to
um Gandalf
um there's one or two that could have
been attributed to radagast they were
kind of radagasty you know and I think
there was are we saying that to Wood are
we we're out of gas station
right now and there's like one or two
things that he did that was kind of uh
sourmet kind of you know the death of
the fireflies you know so it's like
I think they they you know it's like we
don't know who he is you know but he
does have character well he is a wizard
and maybe all of these guys all of these
Wizards had some sort of characteristics
before they really fleshed out who they
were after their fall to Middle Earth
um
Saruman never says if he goes to the
Eastern night and you know he's he's not
really all that in tune with the good
side all the time so that might be the
sleeper kind of
here here you go
well
Christopher Lee yes yes well you know
sour man's like you know his last
Direction was straight down the tower
to the ground
they called
Landing
they like when evil Eminem and his two
friends found him they thought he was
Sauron and then and then they just
called him the other don't they so it
may sound like he's very powerful but
wasn't galdolf not really
fat and Powerful compared to other
beings another is a very important
character but was he actually like a
particularly powerful character compared
to Saruman and well he he was uh when he
became Gandalf the White when he was
after he killed after he killed and died
after killing the ballroom then he did
return his Gandalf to White he
definitely leveled up and then he became
a um and then he became the uh perfect
spoil for uh sauerman in terms of how
but the way they sort of called him the
other made it sound like he was sort of
like
to do with Sauron somehow like like he's
the mirror of Sauron or like that that
they were connected somehow he's like oh
he's not sorry he's the other that seems
a bit loaded to me like that should make
a point but he's an e star like an angel
even he should still be at a much higher
level even as if if it is Gandalf the
Gray it should still he should still at
least be more powerful than the the
Eminem knockoff band over there
that's great
I didn't love him in this this
um character that that was the best bit
for the the last episode of me was the
fight between them and those three
whatever the hell they were and Priests
of Sauron or something I don't know what
they were but
um they were cool I like that they would
have been like would would they have
been fallen angels of some kind stormy
or no because I I know Gandalf radagast
Saruman they're they're all Easter right
so isn't it Sauron is an annotar isn't
it or am I misconstruing things uh well
it's
um as to the who the are you asking like
who the evil Eminem could be
um
I'm trying to guess power levels here
because no matter what any of the East
tar would have been more powerful than
the m m cover band
Yes yes
even if it is fourth grade level down
you know right you know and so and right
now we're seeing whoever it is the the
Wizard metamorphosis after you you know
I mean got shot out of a meteor into the
ground and then started you know
recognizing who you or whatever that
transformation is
uh I would say they are more powerful
than uh the evil Eminem character
okay you know I mean because if you go
back to uh The Hobbit and um the battle
that uh L Ron and gladriel and Gandalf
did with Sarah on The Necromancer uh you
see that it's um
I mean they the elves especially are
are very warlike creatures I mean you
don't own an angered elf is a very
dangerous thing it's like an angry
warlock you never anger a vorlon
um so I would say because it once you go
up from the wizard level then you
definitely you're in Sauron territory
and
I don't think
there is a character power magic level
in between those two
you know it's unless you and I'm really
don't want to pimp out Tom babadook
again but I he was the only person that
was totally unaffected by the One Ring
of Power you know he's just like uh
can do he was totally he
unaffected by it
everybody else was except tom Bob Young
who the [ __ ] is Tom Bombadil we don't
actually have an answer for that right
we don't know if he's fallen anything or
um he is God Tom Bombadil is God there's
a man if you really want to you know get
into a fist fight just go on some of
these Tolkien discords and just say well
you know and just say Tom bobadill was
fill in the blank someone's going to
beat you up
was a good guy someone's gonna come and
beat you up because they believe me
opposites
tokens are crazy
angry
but anyway so as a whole
and I know what storm is going to say
but if you had to like describe that
what you feel about the Lord of the
Rings franchise what we've seen so far
and what we're looking forward to
how would you how would you sum it up
now that we've seen the season finale
stormy first you have a storm you ever
think Harris you go you go first you
have the studio Harris
am I I'm up first yeah
individually or write it just
accordingly
and what are you looking are you looking
forward to the next series really
I'm okay so the one thing it definitely
did was make me look forward to what's
to come so now I'm kind of pissed off
that they're filming it right now
instead of filming it back to back so we
get season two next year because they
said it's gonna be two or three years
till we get season two but I'm looking
forward to it when it does arrive
I don't know if I feel satisfied from
the first season but I'm next to it
and I still just love Middle Earth
itself so much and all the things it
brings that I I'm going to hop back into
it the second I have the opportunity to
but I'm not like I'm excited but I'm not
ecstatic where I know after a house I
hate to compare it again but after House
of the dragon's gonna be done bring me
season two I I need it this one I'm like
all right well I got two years
maybe it'll grow on me in that two years
hopefully
why would it take two years a movie if a
movie was filming now it would be out
within 12 to 18 months at a maximum
um
2013.
like November 10 years ago
20 20. now it's they they said I mean
it's not going to be done filming till
with a show this large it's going to
take them
as long if not longer to film than I
would assume a a big Blockbuster film
which is like six to nine months we're
Googling like crazy I'm guessing late
2024 at the earliest if not like spring
2025
the contract that they have with the
talking state has with the with Amazon I
think
states that they'd have to have a much
more quicker um production or a release
schedule
doing that
foreign
it's going to be it's supposed to be in
the first quarter of 2024. so yeah
18 months
wow that is proper like big this that's
this type of movie sort of time frame
that's like a second Avengers almost
just
because of the because of the CGI that
the CGI is just
um
sometimes you can create a lot of the
CGI beforehand but when it's so
interactive with the person you have to
do it the way you have to film first and
then CJ and you get a massive gap
between the two especially with them
having to film hard foots and things
like that and have to juxtapose
uh just the size of individuals on
screen all at once too I mean that's
well you know and yeah season one took
18 months to film
yeah okay
uh it's gonna be a big gap
um
so stormy there what what did what what
do you think I know I know you loved it
and I know you're looking forward to the
second season but can you sum it up in
why we should all be excited about it
uh well you know you're right I loved it
and I'm looking forward to the second
season uh well it's I think you guys are
on to something when you say that it
went head to head with House of dragon
which is a completely different thing
and um
why Amazon did that I have no idea you
know they you know if they pushed it
back you know 10 weeks or accelerated to
10 weeks the the release get probably
it'd have been better if they uh put it
off 10 weeks then they would have had
like you know that would have been the
thing that everybody was going to watch
because I don't think there's any real
big releases coming up in the next few
you know weeks after House of dragon and
I can recall no big huge fantasy things
and they'd have had it all to themselves
all the way through Christmas
you know and uh I think that would have
been offended the production I mean it
it it's a it's a different type of show
but it is it's a um
uh yeah I think it's well worth anyone's
time it is I will say you know
um one of the commentaries
I've read that that is a valid point
is that uh rings of power is fantasy the
whole family can watch
yes uh they can't let their kids watch
the birth scene of the first episode of
Queen
there's very little scenes that they can
show that that uh you know 12 year olds
can mentally healthily
see from the house of dragon
God the problem is with house the dragon
and Game of Thrones you never know what
you might have to explain
well that's just you know I've got kids
my lab asked me yesterday and he's 13
years old when can I watch how when can
I watch them
um yeah Game of Thrones and I was
thinking about like going
right their brother and their sister how
do I explain that [ __ ]
you can never mate you're not watching
it you're not
banned when you're 18 years old you're
going I say in a couple of years we'll
let them watch it but I'm not watching
it with him
anything you want to ask don't Google it
I mean
that much worse actually
I mean the things that are our
that Tolkien speaks of that is most
critical is his uh opinions that is in
the text of the negative opinions he has
of war and um
uh technological
um advancement
you know look because he um
I think he's born in Birmingham grew up
in Birmingham was that correct a really
industrial town it's pronounced
boomingham Birmingham
he's from Alabama
he's an Alabama man surprise you know
and then he goes off to war
um and that great I mean you know he
just Mordor is what essentially what he
lived through uh there's a film
um that's just call token it's it's it's
a biopic of his oh he I'm not of his of
him and
um it's really it I like it and it
really it shows you where he gets these
ideas and he works out a lot of his
feelings from industrialization in uh
the first World War
on paper
um
I'm not sure what George RR Martin's
trying to work out oh my God what did he
go through
you made me just think of it it's almost
where we talked about
well we were saying like
they're very
they're similar concepts of fantasy in
general but we're ones written for for
families in general and one's kind of
written for adult and one's more
medieval fantasy grounded and the other
more Fantastical fun
part of that do you think the the
choices going into the writing of that
at least is Tolkien went through War
himself went through one of the most
grueling Wars Humanity's ever known in a
lot of ways and was like screw this I
need to put a little bit of a
a a nice feather on top I need to I need
to put a little smile on it versus
George RR Martin's not necessarily I
can't speak he's not necessarily
glorifying War by any means no no no but
in a way he never experienced it so he's
just writing it as hard and as as
realistic as he can see it in a certain
sense and he's only writing it that way
because he hasn't experienced it and
wants to run away from it is that a kind
of of course I'm trying to get in their
minds uh you know
um they also both Writers come from
different eras like you know it's oh
yeah completely Jordan R Martin is
nowhere near old enough to uh even fight
in World War II you know I mean uh
uh and also Tolkien was writing
um
you know he was really his goal was to
write mythology
and so the writing styles he uses are
all mythological and scope you know
concerning like a
um Homer and as was as a an example of
another mythological writer Iliad in The
Odyssey
um
Martin is I don't wanna I don't want to
call it pop fantasy because I don't
think it is pop fantasy I mean it's
definitely heavy fantasy but it's just
it's a totally different
sub-genre you know it's just like
um the uh sort of Shannara is a whole
different type of fantasy than the other
two
um yeah I think it should you know it's
it's
um
we just because we're calling both of
them fantasies doesn't mean it's the
same kind of story or the same
um
the same writing style you know it's
like look at all the varieties in horror
I mean pinheads up Disney princess now
so we have all these different you know
types of
um stories within a the symbol in the
same genre it's a good question for both
of you then just just I think because
obviously Lord of the Rings has I'm
sorry rings of power has
um separate the audience people really
don't like this show
there's a lot of people that really
didn't like Michelle before they've even
seen it so and then just double down
after they did see it but is this show
rings of power 10 years too late is the
has the audience changed
partly because of Game of Thrones
and maybe their expectation
has changed
I have no idea I mean I I think a lot of
the people you know certainly there
there was the the trollish aspect going
into it you know people bitching about
it uh because
um
you know just just to [ __ ] about it and
sometimes I think I'm wondering if a lot
of these trolls are just parts of ad
agencies like you know that's uh I mean
it would not surprise me at that age if
HBO came out and it went out
uh was guilty of hiring trolls just to
down the the Amazon product and boost up
the HBO you know House of dragons
product I mean the [ __ ] that goes down
in advertising would stun you I was an
Advertiser for two years and the [ __ ] I
did
foreign
has the audience changed
has the audience changed for
um
The Odyssey
um exactly
yeah that's a good point Eli and David
in the chat just said Eli said if Lord
of the Rings was made now people would
hate it and and that's true in a lot of
ways people I think nowadays we're kind
of all of us are looking at things
through a very um
we're all trying to be not reviewers in
our own ways but we're all much harder
on things now than we were 20 years ago
obviously I was three at that point so
I'm much harder on things now than I was
back then but for for everybody back in
the day you know uh I I feel like little
Harris was going [ __ ] Daffy Duck you
know three years old I had some strong
opinions back then you know
in their tribes is mum this cartoon's
crap
I just want a Darkwing Duck no Daffy no
no Donald just Dark Wing
no but uh David B says right after no
good stories last a lifetime
and I he's got an excellent point where
if this was happening 10 years ago would
we have this instead of The Hobbit
would people be happier that we have
this instead of The Hobbit or would
people still you know I don't know I'd
still prefer The Hobbit over rings of
what we got here I the the first and the
third I don't know about the second one
I'd be that'd be interesting to see what
people would rate a chance I haven't
given it a chance so I keep saying it's
terrible and I don't know because I've
only watched half an hour of the first
one I need to give it a chance so my
opinion really is irrelevant on that
what was that was it uh Jay that didn't
like the singing
I had about 45 minutes of the dwarf
singing and I got bored and turned it
off
because that's what Builder wagon takes
so carefully
thanks song for so long though come on
it was just went oh no I I went and
built a shed came back and they were
still singing
are you sure you weren't like Martin
Freeman's double during that time period
because I I think that's exactly like
that was like his that was the scene
right there
um
yeah you know and of course wait till
you get the king to the king of Goblin
Town
okay that sounds like fun he has a bit
of addition to say my lad has watched
all three and he says I'm being an idiot
and I should watch them because
sorry we all know that's true
say it
let me see just because I called you
Danny DeVito a couple of weeks ago it
wasn't even me somebody else said it
strikes again
that's right I'm getting my hat hang on
uh we'll be back in a minute and then
Disney they've got Willow and it's gonna
blow both of these shows out the water I
cannot wait for Willow it's gonna be
awesome I'm very glad you finished that
with both of these out of the water I
thought you were about to say Willow was
gonna blow and I was just about to just
hang my head I'm so excited
then again
that's the next t-shirt design I'm doing
and again
um I'm joking I'm not even joking about
Willow I saw the advert for it then
sneak peek next week it looks freaking
amazing yeah
that's um
I just I just wish him that he uh Val
Kilmer was was well well he's gonna be
in it that was just about to ask how are
they gonna do mad Mart again because he
they confirmed Val Kilmer is 100
involved in in a heavy position involved
with the show I just don't I can't
and he's not in the trailer at all so
they're holding that back
that's what people want but I can't see
him being in it a lot he's not well
no but I love Val Kilmer I love Val
Kilmer I think that's his best movie
will I I I hand on heart thing that's
his best movie well have you seen the
doors
yes
okay very different but
he he was Jim Morrison for that okay let
me rephrase my word and then that Willow
is his most entertaining movie
and I'm including Batman Forever
[Music]
skip over that comment
about my oh got the Batman movies we
could talk about the Batman movies so
well and that's a different stream
George George Clooney with the nipples
was the uh was the The Pinnacle of just
what the hell well Val Kilmer started
the bad nipples right they were just
much less prominent yeah well so maybe
um
don't even want to Google Val Kilmer bat
nipples I mean what in the hell am I
going to get
that's one of those things where maybe
Google
I watched the
so that Canadian guy that does the
um the the breakdowns but it's the same
talking to an executive it's the right
to talking executive what the hell is it
called now did it on screen around pitch
meetings the pitch meetings and I saw
the pitch meeting for Batman and he
basically pointed out that all the way
through the first Batman movie Michael
Keaton's a sex press and I'm just like
if honestly go and watch it just Google
the pitch meeting for the Batman and
watch it I mean you'll come away from it
thinking that the Batman the first
Batman movie was a very different film
it's the one you remember
those pitch meetings can they're funny
as hell for literally everything but
when they do the good movies and then
they still tear them apart and make
sense with the tearing apart it just it
makes me laugh so hard but like my heart
just sinks all at once yeah I love them
though
Willow can't be woke can't be held
it's it's it's Wizards and stuff how can
it be woke and then no no I don't
believe it I don't believe it damn it uh
I hope God I hope dude I've got nowadays
I never used to this they've always made
bad TV shows and bad movies and every so
often you'll catch a really bad movie on
Netflix and they go oh God I forgot how
[ __ ] this was so I mean making Hollywood
making bad stuff is not new no I feel
like more recently though that every
time you watch something you go into it
a little bit more trepidation than she
used to it was am I just getting older
maybe but it's like a like oh God and
watch this gone oh God I know this is
going to be shocking I'm just
and well like like my three-year-old
self said a minute ago 20 years ago Lord
of the Rings you know people were
probably like this isn't going to be
great but then super excited after the
fact but we weren't going in with that
same kind of not so Rosy tinted glass uh
we're a little more hazy hazy tint
towards what we're going through we're
we're like we have to get through a
layer of fog before people actually like
things nowadays I think the things we
remember is that people forget the
really bad movies the the really bad
stuff we forget about it and it's only
when you sort of go back and look you
remember the good stuff so you it's at
that that rose colored tentacles
spectacles thing what do you think about
the 90s oh my there's such great movies
in the 90s yeah there were some great
movies but there was also some utter
[ __ ]
and in the 80s in the 70s and
um so I think I think that's a
that's an element of it that that
everyone thinks
20 years ago is amazing because you only
remember the good bits and it's
important to watch all the bad stuff too
I I feel like a lot of the times
nowadays just because there are so much
on all these different streaming
services still being released in
theaters yada yada yada and from every
single angle we have new things all the
time and they're all very Niche which is
awesome because you can really go
towards what you want to watch
but in in that same kind of way you
don't necessarily watch you're not
watching what you don't want to watch
you're not like okay well this is what
the the
pop cultures that guys is talking about
right now let me try it out oh that was
crap let's talk about it people just
skip over that and figure out the next
thing that they think they're going to
like at least well also I mean the bad
stuff doesn't get repeated so yeah so I
mean there's a very practical reason why
we don't remember it because someone
like oh that was a [ __ ] film let's let's
never show that again and we forget
about it
let's go or readdress the the issue of
uh
uh was
um rings of power made 10 years too late
um one and it got me thinking on how we
perceive
good films good books bad films bad
books sometimes good music Bad music
um
did Homer when he wrote The Iliad did he
have a publisher or an editor he had to
satisfy
15 of each
okay you know where Peter Jackson had to
deal with new line and show riders for
rings of power has to deal with Jeff
Bezos
and
um
I mean your you know and
uh thing behind the solo had to deal
with uh Disney yeah Mickey Mouse which
you know are we looking is this are we
being presented are these uh
films that the audience won or or are
these are the are the filmmakers making
stuff the audience want or what the
producers and the uh
these Studios want you know and because
Mark Twain
he really didn't have a publisher just
like okay give me another [ __ ] book
you know and I'll publish it
you know
um
the the authors of the ancient sagas
didn't have a publisher it was it was
told
by one generation passing down to the
next
and I guess the the the
um auditor of those stories was like
well I'll embellish this I'll drop that
because I didn't I didn't like that part
of the story and so they always evolved
are we you know so the question is uh
would it hold up today and so I have to
ask I have to ask myself what would the
rules or the marketing advice that the
studio execs took for The Fellowship of
the Ring
are they using that same data to make
rings of power and how much of these
stories and unless so
um uh the movie solo into this it really
should have been titled Chewbacca and I
think everybody would have liked liked
it better so they're entitled to let
something yeah so I mean are we are we
looking at the filmmakers or we're
looking at marketing firms telling the
executives what people want to see and
how much does that Rob us of what the
real storytellers want to do
is that it shocks me how much because
you know it's like there's there's
people that I talk to mostly about
Stargate and stuff and it shocks me how
many times it comes up there is in a
marketing meeting and this happened and
we're in a marketing meeting and this it
seems to be that the marketing meeting
is what happens first
nowadays wouldn't I doubt it you know
it's not like it seems to be there's the
Michael Wright guy that's the guy that's
going to make the final decision on
Stargate and but he is way down the line
you know it's like
um I did a video last week saying that
um there was a apparently according to
someone I spoke to there was a meeting
uh last week about Stargate and they
were talking about how they want to move
on and they've seen by January 15th they
want a decision because they want to
announce it for when
um epics becomes MGM plus so they want
to announce it just before but that's
the marketing team saying that yeah
it seems to me that the marketing team
are the the first ladder sort of thing
it's going to get past them before
anything else happens
and I don't think that was true 10 years
ago
even if you go back about 15 maybe 15 20
years it was 15 years
um
um Kanye West had this
um
reality show on MTV about this rap you
know putting together a rap group you
know I can't wait to see where this is
going okay
was it an Eminem cover band
Jesus
so but no it was so they're in there
right and they he's got the these the
the
um
the musicians together trying to make
some sort of band right trying to make
you know kind of like the monkeys I
guess a manufactured band
and so in the marketing meeting and and
they have and they showed that there
they have this marketing meeting going
on well what's the band's name what are
they about and it's really not the band
members
trying to say what they're about or what
their their the motivation for the
lyrics are it's like how can we present
them and what is there uh what is their
uh message to the people I mean you know
it's like um
it was manufactured you know it wasn't
like something spontaneous like Wu-Tang
Clan which was a kind of a spontaneous
group
um but yeah and so there's
uh in in these marketing guys who I know
a lot of them
or what they're like they're not they're
not English lit majors
at all
they're NBA's they know dick about an
Arts
you know the only art they care about is
is this uh um uh ad campaign gonna boost
their um sales of the soft cookie Market
one percent that's their conversation
and by the way the soft cookie Market
one percent is actually a conversation I
had to endure on a flight to Los Angeles
Once Upon a Time from to January
yeah so um
look actually genuinely talking to a few
different people
um about Target I I can't believe how
these decisions are actually made it is
genuinely shocking it seems so
Petty almost how some of these decisions
are made and some of the things that
they consider and can we make a good
show seems to be it's not on the agenda
it's not on the docket when they're
deciding whether it seems to be who can
we sell it to
yeah how does it help
these different markets or how does that
nowadays it's how do how does it help us
get subscribers that's that's the
initial conversation that advertising
doesn't come into it as much anymore
yeah it's how can we how can we get how
does this get us more subscribers how
does this how does this affect social
media how does this think and then it's
like how can we get endorsements that
seems to be the next thing they talk
about that I hear quite a lot is how how
does this how can we sell this show to
not advertisers but people that will
give us money to put an Audi or you know
but will Audi want to invest and put a
car in the show will Coca-Cola want to
give us some money so something and that
seems to be the next show and then it's
like you haven't even talked about
whether the show's going to be any good
or not yeah the prancing pony IPA
um you know
it is it's sad that there's a lot of
really good stories a lot of really good
media that are just rejected because
they can't there's no place to put the
Audi I mean I I've heard conversations
where you know uh properties you know um
especially comic books and and
specifically where
great stories great stories are passed
over because there's not really any uh
branding opportunities
[Music]
to help support the film
you know and and uh is that is looking I
think everybody wants wants to be
uh George Lucas
with his relationship with Hasbro you
know I mean um George Lucas when he um
um we made American Graffiti he was had
[ __ ] you money you know I mean if you
just do whatever he could do a film for
what everyone and he said let's do Star
Wars and everyone was what the hell is
that no one got behind the film I think
the guy that really promoted it to the
studios I think he's either fired or
quit or something during the production
of Star Wars and so Lucas just kept
giving up all of his you know whatever
it takes to get a little bit more he
gave up his salary et cetera says well
okay fine um
um you know and he ended up with the you
know the uh permanent toy franchise for
it and he would sell those rights off
and my God the the Hasbro for all the
toys that those contracts probably more
valuable than the film itself
and so when you get like you know when
you get to that point
uh in in in either Hollywood power or
money you can kind of do what you want
but those those opportunities and those
people are few and far between you know
I mean even a in an E.T still Steven
Spielberg had
more marketing dollars you know for
Reese's Pieces yeah the the agreement
they had the green machine with the
studio to make Schindler's List and part
of the agreement was you'd have to make
hook
you know so they said look we've got
this thing that we can sell the crap out
of hook and it's great and Steven
Spielberg was like I don't really I was
like look we will fund Schindler's List
to film you desperately want to make if
you make hook and that but that was that
was Contracting that was part of the
agreement and that was Spielberg about
five years ago he was the height of his
game you know he really should have been
able to go I'm making and then the film
producers you know the movie should have
been like Steve whatever you want to do
me yeah you know whatever you want but
they know he still had to negotiate to
make a film as powerful and as important
as Schindler's List
he had to negotiate and yeah you know
I'm just like that's amazing how these
things work it's it it amazes me that it
shouldn't really but it amazes me that
these decisions are made by so few
people as well yeah and it comes down to
I I've suggested that um
um Michael Wright is the head of
scripted and if we want
[Music]
um
to really get star Stargate made let's
all write him a letter and I put it on
the Community page today and I've
actually put um the address of the
headquarters for MGM headquarters in in
Beverly Hills and just let's all write
Michael write a letter a polite letter
somebody else come back and go shall I
send him a dead squirrel because no
don't send him look don't do that send
them a very polite letter saying please
bring back Stargate and maybe
what does it say about us you know
growing an audience that would think
sending a dead squirrel to Michael
Wright is what we're wanting him to do I
mean
yeah
you're a [ __ ] genius but then I
thought no that probably won't work
but if we get to February or not next
year if you want to just send him a bag
of poo the address works too much next
year we still haven't got Stargate
you know
if somebody's going to get the dead
Squirrel it should be the marketing guys
yeah well like I say the more I hear
about what goes on I don't I don't share
a lot of what I hear about it because
it's it's boring and nobody really wants
to hear and nobody listens to watch a
video but the more I the more I'm told
by like so this one guy in particular
that works quite he works illegal stuff
and he tells me a lot and some of the
stuff he tells me I'm just like ah for
[ __ ] sake
um it's just it's just ridiculously is
how these things work absolutely
is that what they eat for Thanksgiving
in Canada Canadian Thanksgiving am I
because I'm a dad and my my brain is
practical I was thinking oh the postage
in that is going to be ridiculous
straight away I could afford a squirrel
but
um
you have to send Shelly some money to
help out all that
um you go after FedEx that [ __ ]
all right guys
um
so thank you so much again it's been a
brilliant chat and we didn't get to talk
we're not done yet we're not done yet
that's what we watched this last week oh
[ __ ] it broke okay and we usually start
off with that we've been talking about
it for an hour and a half did you well
we talked about three shows yeah the
three shows we watched
there is one yes so start off Jay what
did you see this week
um the other thing I really watched
other than what we've already talked
about is obviously when I say every damn
week uh lower decks which was good I
really enjoyed it they did that whole um
sequel to one of the things that if they
did a hollow movie and they were sort of
sovereign class starship in it and it
was just freaking brilliant and there
was no awkward humor like in the
uh bloody Bird Man Snogging the little
robot thing and then having making sweet
love there was none of that
which I appreciated
um have you seen last week's do you know
what I'm talking about
next
oh dear God the bird episode is cringing
but it's still very funny in places but
it was cringy but last week's was
phenomenal but you know what I've
actually started watching again which
I'm enjoying it's not quite sci-fi but
I've started watching Buffy the Vampire
Slayer again
I've skipped a lot of the first season
because it's not very good
um but I started watching and Angels
just become evil and I'm like oh man I
am back in my early 20s this is bloody
room and I've forgotten how much I fancy
Mr Sam Michelle Geller really likes him
well I was kind of shocked when I found
found out that uh Dolly Parton
was a big Thunder
of that show yes really a lot of yeah it
was her production company that kind of
said oh you know Dolly thought this was
a great idea
so let's do it yeah she put a lot of
money to the I forgot the name of the
friction company
every episode uh like a zombie thing but
yeah she put a lot of money back into
that it wouldn't have happened did
nobody do it like Dolly do it like Dolly
yeah
um but I haven't actually I don't think
I've watched much else
so go on stormy what do you think so um
yeah when I um right before code I moved
to California and so I stopped watching
uh Walking Dead
you know so the thing I binged this week
was um definitely getting back to
Walking Dead and I'm halfway through the
last season I'm almost caught up with
the most recent broadcast
think
and it's it's even with that kind of a
several year
um absence you know just it's amazing to
me how well the story
held up after I stopped watching it and
how still engaging it was and
and the thing I I I've remarked about
the writing
this last week that I've been watching
it is
how the writers were able to reform the
character Negan
um it's like
you know uh they have one whole episode
of negan's backstory of how Negan became
Negan how he got the ball bat how he got
the jacket and it is it is just
heartbreaking it is heartbreaking how
all that developed and it's like oh
now we know why Megan was Negan for a
little bit for the dark Negan period and
then we have the repentant Negan period
and
um it was just really good you know in
fact as soon as we get off here I got to
do a load of laundry but we'll put that
[ __ ] in and then I'm going to start
walking in the last few episodes
because it was just really compelling
even after all these years still going
to and I think this is the last year of
The Walking Dead because there's a
couple spin-offs that I still have to
also catch up with I haven't caught up
with those
but
um I was it was it was a writing
challenge to get somebody as evil as
Negan to seem sympathetic
before you know understanding why he
became evil Negan and why it and make it
so powerful that even Maggie
the wife of the guy that he brutally
killed in the first episode we see Negan
can almost kind of forgive him
almost
which and and it's it's it was it was
really powerful writing you know and
and um whoever's running the shows over
at AMC
for needs to get on needs to work for
emgm it sounds like because you know the
the AMC guys really have their [ __ ]
together because they can really put
together a story sometimes they miss
Rubicon and sometimes they really hit it
out of the park creature
yeah I hate zombie things I think I've
told you before give me a rifle enough
ammunition I sort out to him any zombie
apocalypse in a couple of hours I just
don't worry but um is it Negan did he
say he was his name
the actor that plays his character is
just one of those actors I wish he'd
been in other it's just brilliant
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is fantastic Morgan
um he said if Uncle loses
um Chris Evans and that isn't it and I
wish that film got a sequel I thought it
was great
um but it's uh it wasn't it wasn't
massively popular but it was it was
great movie Idris Elba was in it and Zoe
salawana was in it and uh yeah yeah you
know that was it yeah and it's um
oh God what was the name of the villain
and he was overcome by this one
gentleman's shortness and he looks at
him are you standing in a hole I mean he
was just
I watched together a year ago June I
think I launched it again during
lockdown but um
uh so the um the first thing I saw him
in he was playing the comedian in the
Watchman yep first thing I remember him
from and I thought and then that was a
really good performance yeah I've always
wanted to work on American soil yes Zack
Snyder wanted to bring him back if he
was going to finish all of his Justice
League Trilogy stuff as the Thomas Wayne
version of Batman and one of those dream
sequences or something like that
we don't need to get in all this Zack
Snyder stuff but that was possible we'll
be here all day
what have you been watching ours
anything well
uh I watched Hellraiser I I was I was
talking about watching it last week
finally watched it I really like the new
one I it's probably my second favorite
behind the original
I watched Halloween ends and liked it
significantly more than I thought it was
as well yes I enjoyed it as well I I
went in with the lowest of low of the
lowest of low expectations and
I'm sorry uh go ahead no no
is that in the theaters or out on the
you know like a streaming service
holidays
yes
both
um which which is why I was went in with
the lowest of low of low of expectations
because a Studio's knock if they do that
now still that to me signals that they
are not very
they don't have confidence in in the
product is that the modern equivalent of
straight to DVD yes it is no I don't
think that's fair
a strength DVD is not the same as
straight to streaming not Mac there's
too much money and streaming
but it has to bring new subscribers and
streaming if there's no adverts it has
to bring new subscribers and it is kind
of similar in those same format where
straight to DVD okay that was back in
the day where no no they're they're not
counting on a theatrical release at all
it is going straight to DVD or a TV
movie per se whatever it may be and they
hope
they know that that's not going to get
new subscribers per se but they're
putting it there so people watch it
hopefully but they're also releasing it
in theaters at the same time just to
hope for a couple dollars that's that's
where they're looking for money there
they're not thinking they're going to
get new subscribers off of it per se or
they would have pushed it and only made
it a peacock thing they would have done
that like prey or Hellraiser for Hulu or
or the Samaritan for Amazon Prime
something like that where this is kind
of it's not all eggs in a basket it's
thrown spaghetti at a wall and hoping
something sticks you know it's kind of
just how I look at that I I enjoyed it
but it was a um
it was a it was just another it was
basically just
because they had Halloween ends already
as far as I was in the the last movie
was Halloween ends and I enjoyed that as
well
um it was great but um yeah but it was
enjoyable horror movie I don't
particularly like horror movies but um I
I I enjoyed it a good film I would watch
it again
um I thought it was a decent
psychological Slasher
but not necessarily your best Halloween
movie
and I think they advertised it wrong
because all the advertisements that were
there for it all the trailers anything
and everything was just about the
Michael fight with Jamie Lee Curtis and
all that sure which is literally the
last 15 minutes of the movie there's a
whole movie in front of everything yeah
and we we didn't even realize Corey that
guy was gonna be a character at all I
mean Michael Myers almost gets an
apprentice is the basis of this movie
and it's it's more of a psychological
slasher and I like that aspect of it and
I think it escalated it as a film but
not necessarily as your fun Halloween
slasher movie that people wanted and
expected you know so I think
I think in a couple of weeks we will
have a Halloween
episode we'll talk about some of our
favorite Halloween movies from over the
years not not necessarily sci-fi but
screw it I'm in charge I can talk about
whatever I want or we're in charge we
can talk about whatever we want yeah so
um I think we'll have a Halloween
episode week after next
okay so let's do that
all right then guys that was Rick and
Morty though and I gotta end on Rick and
Morty fantastic but now it's gone for
six weeks
oh sad
but it was fantastic
stormy you look like they look like
something was gonna you looked up at all
wistfully like something was brewing oh
it is so his nightmare on Christmas a
Halloween movie or a Christmas movie
I'll tell you I cannot wait for that new
Santa the Santa Claus movie that's
coming out this year I can't remember
it's bloody cold I put it all over the
thing what was the um uh with with David
Harbor yeah
is it a violent night violent night
that's it violent night oh my God I want
to watch that movie so much
it looks so good it's it's what Die Hard
would be if Santa was actually in it uh
you know
I can't wait I really really want to see
that film but right guys it is Die Hard
a Christmas movie yes it is oh yeah I
think that it's the greatest Christmas
movie something we all agree on even
though the director said it's not and
Bruce Willis said it's not but it is
so they're wrong
um and so is that hard too
Merry Christmas
my favorite we all had to wear our
Christmas jumpers for um Christmas last
year and I had mine with ho ho ho now I
have a machine gun
Christmas jumper but it's written it
looks just like from the movie I was
like I was so proud everyone else is
there with like stupid Santa Clauses
thing and they're going I'm wearing a
proper Christmas jumper
um right guys let's call it in the
evening sure
thank you so so much it's nice that you
don't want to go storming
but go we must so I do have to do
laundry I apologize yes and I I you're
trying to fall asleep on that side of
the world and and me and Danny Gandolf
are just waking up over here
oh oh it's Pitch Black in here
um it's awesome all the leaves are
changing
[Laughter]
I still need to find out if Danny DeVito
has a catch race that we could throw
into this I need to watch more Danny
DeVito stuff
guys It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
just binge it all uh
guys thank you so so much
go and check out in the description
there is a link to uh stormy's uh
Facebook group
stormy's YouTube channel
um SCI Works which is like our more
intelligent cousin on Sidetrack when I
was thinking upside track I might have
accidentally stolen at least half your
name for your Channel
I didn't mean to completely accidental
but anyway so it works
my most popular video this week with me
making a microscope out of a laser don't
ask me why you just got this this crazy
ass jump
DIY laser microscope go watch yes
there is also a video where he plays
with
um hydrogen and doesn't blow himself oh
I was so disappointed he kept his
eyebrows
yeah
I watched that so excitedly I was like
yeah
no nothing and you could also in the
description find a link to the Young
Americans and on M cubed where he talks
about lots and lots of fascinating
things and I promise
um I've
so okay a little bit you don't talk
about that as much as I thought you
would after a minute so well we we have
a couple videos and they're just long
videos that take forever to be edited
and we have to finish we have we're
doing full cannabis feasts so we're
doing like edibles but full meals out of
them and it takes a little while to get
those together get people together and
all that but
because donors take forever to do
everything
so check that out y'all excellent and
those are the ones we love and obviously
we're doing a few more videos for the
Sidetrack Channel as well when a sci-fi
movie comes out so we look forward to
those guys thank you so so much as
always it's been absolutely brilliant
I'm trying to find the outro I can never
find it but I found it there
bye guys
toodle
[Music]